. So during yesterday's White House Corona
virus press briefing, there was a truly chilling
moment that needs a little bit of explanation.
Donald Trump at one point literally stepped
up to the podium and would not allow Dr. Anthony
Foushee to answer a question about hydrochloric
acid hydroxide, chloroquine or chloroquine.
This one of many possible therapeutic treatments
for coronavirus that is currently being tested.
And instead of explaining the whole backstory
first, I'm just going to play the video for
you and then I'm going to give you the whole
story after that.
Also, weigh in on this issue of Hydroxy LAUCHLAN.
What do you think about this and what made
me a doctor?
Fifteen year old.
He's your medical expert, correct?
Answer the question.
Fifteen years.
So Dr. Foushee stands there looking uncomfortable.
And Donald Trump makes it clear Dr. Foushee
doesn't have to answer meaning.
Dr. Foushee should not answer that question.
And then another question gets yelled up.
So what is this all about?
So here's the backstory.
Trump has been talking about hydroxy chloroquine
for a while now as a possible game changer.
The big possible cure for the virus.
And the truth is, it's one treatment that
is being tested.
There are some significant side effects.
It's a high risk thing for people with certain
cardiac situations.
And there are conflicting studies about is
chloroquine better than placebo and or the
established course of treatment or not.
So Trump has been pretty irresponsible in
touting it constantly saying what do you have
to lose by trying it?
Of course, some people potentially would lose
their lives by trying it.
People are trying to stockpile it.
Certain governors have been picking it up.
There are shortages for people who take the
medication for its actual approved conditions
like lupus and some others.
Now, every time Foushee has been asked about
it in the in the past, he will say something
like, listen, it's a good drug for some conditions.
We don't have any data yet that says it is
actually effective for coronavirus.
We need proper randomized controlled trials
for using this medication.
Unkovic, 19, period.
But when I saw this and I saw Trump immediately
jump in and prevent Dr. Foushee from answering
the question, I suspected there was more to
it.
And case in point, in the few hours right
after last night's press briefing, we got
that additional information over the weekend.
On Saturday, there was a heated fight in THE
SITUATION ROOM involving Dr. Foushee about
chloroquine and one of Donald Trump's bomb
throwers.
Peter Navarro was fully in it and apparently
furious with Dr. Foushee.
So this happened Saturday afternoon.
Mike Pence was there.
Dr. Foushee was there.
Dr. Birks, Jared Kushner, Chad Wolfe, Steven
Hahn, and indeed, Peter Navarro was.
There is a right wing economist and big time
Trump brownnoser.
When the topic of hydroxy chloroquine was
brought up, Navarro got up and grabbed a big
stack of folders and dropped them onto the
table.
And everybody started looking at the papers
in the folders.
And Navarro said, here are copies of studies
that show that clearly chloroquine works to
treat coronavirus.
And Navarro was pushing for the Trump administration
to talk about it.
Just talk about it like it works tronc.
Talk about it like a proven treatment.
This was too much for Dr. Foushee.
And Dr. Foushee rightly said, this is anecdotal.
This is not data.
These are not our S.A.T.'s randomized controlled
trials.
This is irresponsible.
We can't go out and promote this like a treatment.
Studies that have been done have no or poor
control groups.
There are studies that say this does not work.
So Dr. Foushee is trying to do what a doctor
does, not succumbing to political pressure
from a right wing economist, which is what
Pete Navarro is.
This apparently set off Pete Navarro.
He started angrily pointing to the pile of
folders, saying that science, not anecdote.
Navarro raised his voice, accused Dr. Foushee
of trying to prevent Trump's travel restrictions,
which is crazy since Dr. Foushee from the
beginning praised those travel restrictions.
This is apparently something that in the room
also got.
Looking confused because most people in the
room knew that Dr. Foudre had indeed been
praising the travel restrictions.
So question one is, is it common that people
are yelling at each other during the SITUATION
ROOM meetings about Corona virus?
The answer is no.
This is reportedly the first time that this
happened, but we now have a backstory that
explains what we saw yesterday.
So now knowing the backstory, let's look at
it one more time.
Trump praising hydroxy chloroquine like a
miracle cure, which it has not proven to be.
REPORTER tries to get Dr. Foushee to comment.
And Dr. Foushee not allowed to answer the
question.
So weigh in on this issue of hydroxy LAUCHLAN.
What do you think about this and what I maybe
from.
Fifteen year.
He's your medical expert.
Correct?
Sensible question.
Fifteen years.
That's truly chilling.
Truly chilling, because we have a president
concerned only with the political response
to the virus.
You have an economic adviser, Peter Navarro,
concerned only with the optics of the response
and doing things to try to bolster the stock
market, not actually find and develop safe,
proven cures.
And you now have a doctor literally being
silenced by Trump on the world stage during
a press briefing.